[Music]
mr. YouTube algorithm
sir I have more theories for you let me
take a look at those graphs crap double
crap there's about Westworld there's
nothing good place nobody wants this
high-minded crap what good guy started
bad bad guys dirty good but I think the
viewers would really enjoy seeing you
know what the viewers enjoyed they enjoy
what I tell them to enjoy that's why I'm
here and why you're here so give me some
superhero theories but there aren't any
new movies coming out I don't care go
take up some old gems make something up
about no Japanese show being candid to
the MCU I want there is about spider-man
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
totally called the MC use reimagining of
the Daily Bugle long before its surprise
appearance at the end of far from home
it's no exaggeration to say that I've
spent countless hours thinking about
spider-man's complex boss but recently
when he gave me a bit of a challenge
Reddit user
years ago they tried it's not they tried
it they tried T anyway this reddit user
posted the theory that J jonah Jameson
was illegally selling Peter Parker's
photos to quote from that theory on
reddit it's clear from the spider-man 1
that Peter is the only one that would be
able to take the cinematic high-quality
photos he supplies to the Daily Bugle
however let's look here at the many
publications showcasing these sorts of
photos in spider-man 3 where'd these
publications get the right to publish
these photos as far as we know Peter
doesn't sell his photos to anyone except
the Daily Bugle part of the reason he's
so poor all the time with JJ
consistently low-balling him therefore
it makes sense that these other
publications couldn't have gotten the
photos from anyone except the Daily
Bugle ie Jay jonah Jameson TL DR J Jonah
was selling Peters photos for money
evidenced by other publications having
spider-man photos he didn't give up
Peter to the Green Goblin because of
Peters monetary value to him not because
he is a refined valley dude I don't know
what refined valley dude means think it
just means he's a stand-up guy the point
is this post was as good as flashing the
theory symbol in the sky and I have seen
the call so today we're putting Jade
Jonah on trial to see if he's just an
innocent newsy or a dirty rotten media
scoundrel now as much as I'd love to
write this about the MCU Jameson he's
barely shown up yet and unlike in most
every other spider-man iteration it
seems like Peter and Jameson won't be
working together in the MCU there also
wasn't a J John Jameson in the amazing
spider-man series which honestly is
probably why it was so awful
and you okay maybe it wasn't the only
reason it was so awful that means that
the last time Spidey and J Jonah shared
some serious screen time together it was
back in Sam Raimi's
extremely influential superhero trilogy
I know those movies came out a long time
ago like a long time ago like a chunk of
this audience wasn't even born when the
first one came out think about that one
so I'm just gonna go ahead and refresh
your memory about all the important
details for today's theory after Peter
Parker starts his vigilante work as
spider-man local tabloid editor j jonah
Jameson puts out a cash reward for
pictures of our vigilante Peter being
short on cash decides that he can cheat
the system a bit by taking pictures of
himself and then selling those to
Jameson throughout their time together
Jameson makes it abundantly clear that
he's only out for exactly one thing I
don't parties for some reason a psycho
spider-man will pose for you
the Raimi verse J Jonah very
specifically Commission's pictures of
spider-man from Peter except the one
time Jameson decided to use Peter for
MJ's engagement party anyway when
spider-man goes missing Jameson shows a
moment of regret for his actions before
spider-man steals his own suit from
Jameson's wall spider-man was a hero I
just couldn't see it
it was baked by the third movie jameson
is dangling the promise of a staff
position in front of peter and eddie
brock to entice them to get a picture of
spider-man committing a crime so
throughout this trilogy Peter never
really becomes a full-time employee of
the Daily Bugle this makes it a very
different relationship than say the
relationship between comic book Peter
Parker and comic book J jonah jameson
where peter is a staff photographer who
has even won himself a pulitzer prize
for a shot that wasn't even um spiderman
weird little factoid for you there the
reddit theory alleges that Jameson is
distributing peter parker's photos to
other newspapers but the comment section
actually takes it one step further
saying that this is no longer just shady
business it is outright illegal for J
Jonah to be doing this as user and rayna
chrome says quote he's been ripping
Peter off for years by claiming in his
bugle property from fan mailings and
anonymous sources and reselling the
photo rights without credit or royalties
to Peter why would he admit that to
anyone he could get sued let's talk
about that exactly we've established
that Peter is a freelancer working on
Commission and that he takes pictures of
Spidey in the movies we can see three
major papers and one major magazine none
of which are the Daily Bugle with
excellent quality front page spider-man
pictures a large part of the plot of
spider-man 3 is about how rival
photographer Eddie Brock is incapable of
getting an actual photo of Spidey which
is part of a long string of evidence
that the wall crawler is just very hard
to get on camera
it seems pretty darn clear then that
these photos in the other newspapers
came from Peter by way of the bugle
what's more we know that Peter is
struggling financially and is
desperately trying to get that staff
position at the bugle so it seems like
he's not selling those photos directly
to these other outlets the bugle is his
only buyer which means the only way that
those other papers are getting high-res
photos of the webhead is through Jay
jonah selling peter's pics so you know
what reddit user years ago they tried I
think you're right I think Jonah is
absolutely selling Peters images to
these other publications the thing is
it's also totally within his rights to
do so peter is a freelancer but what
does that mean from a legal standpoint
now here's the point where I say the
standard legal disclaimer that I am NOT
a lawyer
this is not
advice if you or another super-powered
vigilante is having issues with
intellectual property law please contact
she-hulk who is a real fictional lawyer
now you might think that if you create
something then the rights automatically
go to you but that's not always the case
for freelancers most work on things by
commission we see this word all over
Twitter especially for artists designers
photographers sometimes even programmers
but what does working on Commission mean
well in short it means that you're
buying the product that they're making
let's say a Potter makes a coffee mug on
commission it means that they made it
for you same goes with photos of
spider-man commissioned by the Daily
Bugle Jameson is very clearly
commissioning Peters work initially he
puts out an open call for freelancers to
get any pictures of spider-man on the
page cash money for a picture of
spider-man
when Peter brings Jameson pictures of
other things J Jonah
turns him down you're fired there's
really no argument about the nature of
that agreement but here's where things
get tricky unlike a normal transaction
where you buy something and then you
just own it and if you choose to resell
it at like a garage sale or whatever
it's not that big of a deal when it
comes to commissioned artwork or
photography the rights of ownership may
or may not pass over to you if I go on
Twitter and ask user spider Dan 420 to
make art of chibi spider-man for me do I
own that picture now or does he it seems
like a really minor question to ask but
it's really important because the answer
determines who can actually make copies
of that chibi spider-man and sell it to
other big eyed spider fans like myself I
mean I'm the one who came up with the
idea for a chibi spider-man and then I
paid someone to create that image for me
so can i reproduce that image and sell
it is it mine to own or is it still
spider Dan's artwork and here's where
contracts come in specifically
work-for-hire agreements now these are
documents that explicitly state which
rights pass from the freelancer to the
commissioner and which ones don't and
what we don't know the specific terms of
Peter Parker's agreement with J jonah
Jameson we do know that most newspapers
in the real world are paying for full
rights to the photos that they use they
need those photos to be used in print
dull holographic chess boards when it
comes to that from now until the heat
death of the universe because lord knows
they pan no intern to update their geo
cities page twenty years from now for
someone as cutthroat as JJ complete
ownership of all rights across all
platforms in perpetuity is something
that he would absolutely demand from his
Commission photographs and let's be
hundred percent honest it's something
that someone as naive as Peter Parker
would absolutely agree to no questions
asked
that means there's not even an argument
that Peter owns any of the rights to his
photos once they're sold in the Daily
Bugle J Jonah commissioned him fair and
square and from that point forward he
owns them outright sure he got him for a
bargain they were an absolute steal but
that was Peters own fault for being a
bad negotiator and with them properly
commissioned by Jay Jonah there now his
to do with whatever he wants sorry
comment section jay jonah jameson is a
hundred percent within his rights he is
innocent and true to the original theory
posted on reddit selling the photos to
bigger publications is probably a great
source of income for the bugle photo
stock companies like Getty Images work
entirely on licensing images to news
outlets when you license an image you
get to use it for a certain amount of
time or under a specific set of
circumstances for instance only in one
specific printed newspaper or in one
part of the world or online rights only
non-commercial in the case of the Daily
Bugle if they were licensing photos to
other newspapers in the real world they
could also enforce standards like
crediting The Daily Bugle under those
photos linking to the Daily Bugle on
websites with the image and of course
charging licensing fees which brings us
to the question that goes back to the
initial theory how much money could Jay
Jonah actually be making off of Peters
photographs honestly the sky's the limit
this photo of me taking for free at an
event that I did for charity a photo
that I've heavily doctored to make sure
that it falls under fair use so I don't
actually have to pay for it is valued at
$500 same with this picture of me and
other youtubers ringing the Nasdaq Bell
from a few years ago five hundred
dollars and I wouldn't blame you if you
were like wow matpat way to milk it for
cash except all of that is money I will
never
see it's weird they do this a lot at
red-carpet things they take photos of
you and then they just sell the rights
for huge amounts money and you're just
like okay yes I don't get any of that
you're just profiting off of my likeness
it's very very strange anyway that five
hundred dollars isn't even for all the
rights to use that image all the time
now in Spider Man we're talking about
the only good photos in the world of a
superhero who is making front-page
headlines I'd say that's worth a bit
more than me handing out Thanksgiving
dinner to the needy Jay Jonah could
literally name his price for these
photos so we have to agree with the
reddit theory Jonah doesn't want to give
up Peters identity to the Green Goblin
due to journalistic ethics sure he is an
upstanding guy to a certain extent
especially when you read the comics but
it also doesn't hurt that he just so
happens to be protecting not only a nice
kid but also what is certainly his
biggest cash cow
so if Jade Jonah wasn't cheating Peter
out of his photo royalties why is there
so much time left in this video well I
had to find something that Jay Jonah did
wrong and well there is this Spider Man
wasn't attacking the city he was trying
to save it that's slander I resent that
imprint it's libel Jay jonah jameson may
not have sold photos illegally but he
certainly used them illegally let me
introduce you to a much more nefarious
crime in the newspaper business libel
Jay Jonah has unquestionably libeled
spider-man and should be in line to lose
his job his media credentials heck any
cash he has stuffed away in his mattress
because he has got a whole heck of a lot
of lawsuits coming his way
New York libel laws use for
qualifications for a defamation case
defamation just by the way is a kind of
umbrella term for both slander and libel
which are basically the same crime just
done in different mediums
anyway qualification number one has to
involve a false statement anything a
print that's true is just a free pass
you're totally in the clear but we know
from watching the movie that Spiderman
really was saving the city and not
attacking it like Jay Jonah claims the
ski is labelling spider-man's good name
qualification number two fault must
amount to actual malice now this means
that Jameson had to have had some reason
to think that the story wasn't true but
didn't care and published it anyway
Peter who even if he wasn't spider-man
is the photographer of the scene and
thus an eyewitness directly tells
Jameson that the story
isn't true yet Jamison absolutely
doesn't care and publishes anyway this
one is pretty cut-and-dry qualification
number two big checkmark they're liable
qualification number three it must cause
special damages or defamation per se
special damages usually refers to the
financial fallout from slander it costs
someone their job or it cost someone
their business since spider-man is not a
profit generating enterprise that's not
important but what is important is the
defamation part defamation per se
statements are things that impugns a
person's character in other words makes
them appear morally corrupt the
accusations that Jay Jonah leveled at
spider-man both impugn his character and
accuse him of committing morally corrupt
crimes so so far we have ourselves a
good case for three out of the four
pretty rock-solid court case we have
cooking up here rights
I'm sure this fourth qualification
couldn't possibly debunk the case that
we're building rights oh wait
number four defamatory statements must
be published to a third party without
privilege or authorization that's
actually a little bit murky here because
Peter Parker explicitly sells his photos
to Jameson if it happened only the one
time you might make the argument that
Peter didn't know what to expect but the
Raimi trilogy takes place over years as
Peter graduates high school in the first
one and is done with college by the
third Peter works for Jameson throughout
most of these movies Peter definitely
protests about the way J jonah treats
spider-man but his continued work for
the bugle at least indicates that he's
not that man about it and things get
more complicated when you consider the
fact that spider-man's identity is
hidden in the comics spider-man actually
does sujay jonah Jameson for libel but
he drops the case when Peter Parker is
added as a co-defendant for the pictures
he took if the courts were indeed
unaware of Spidey secret identity then
he could claim that they were
unauthorized though he would be lying to
the court and thus guilty of perjury if
the courts do know that Peter Parker and
spider-man are one of the same then all
of a sudden Peter authorized the use of
those photos for the libelous story and
thus is okay with the libel being
published and therefore exonerates J
Jonah from yet another crime as if all
of that weren't enough there is
last obstacle for our intrepid hero to
overcome statute of limitations see
there's no criminal libel law in New
York so spider-man's only recourse would
be going through the civilian courts now
what does that mean well a lot of things
but for our purposes it means that he
has a limited time in which to file his
suit against Jay jonah Jameson the laws
around slander and libel are also
ridiculously outdated in some places
including the state of Virginia where
they seem to be aimed exclusively at
criminalizing yo mama jokes seriously
quote from that law any person who shall
falsely write and publish of and
concerning any female of chaste
character any words derogatory of such
females character for virtue and
chastity or imputed to such female acts
not virtuous and chaste shall be guilty
of libel what is going on over in
Virginia there's a whole law
specifically dedicated to not shaming
the ladies in public writing anyway New
York's criminal libel law is
non-existent but for its civil libel law
the statute of limitations is one year
before spider-man - it's easy to argue
that Jameson was committing libel all
the time recklessly publishing stories
that he knew to be false turn the whole
city against him the fact I'm very proud
of after spider-man retires however
Jameson buys spider-man suit only to
have it stolen from him by spider-man
himself at that point Jameson has all
the evidence he needs to conclusively
say that spider-man is in fact a
criminal Jameson bought the suit fair
and square
spider-man stole it back that wasn't
within his legal rights he committed a
crime by the time spider in three wraps
up Peter has graduated from the college
he was attending in spider-man 2 so any
libelous publications were long in the
past Jade Jonah may be heavily biased
against spider-man but he's a victim of
one of Spidey's admittedly few crimes he
has proof that spider-man is a menace
and actually does have good reason to
believe in spider-man by his own hand
kills the only real chance he has
against Jay Jonah before it even gets
off the ground so what's the lesson here
friends vote for starters superheroes
need to brush up on their legal systems
a little bit better to make sure they're
not complicit with their villains and
maybe they could have like other summer
jobs that don't contribute to their own
negative publicity come on Peter I
thought you were supposed to be the
smart one pretty dumb move there webhead
you could always be a lifeguard if
you're looking for a job
stop running on the pool
Decorah web slinging it to the diving
board but hey that's just a theory a
film theory
and cut
[Music]